According to Gizmodo Australia,
there's one song Aussies play
on Spotify the most during sex.
Let's take a listen
to the greatest song
to get you in the mood
for going Down Under.
(Star Wars Cantina Theme
playing)
-Yeah!
-(laughter)
That'll make your...
that'll make your Force awaken.
-Oh, no! -Of course,
Figrin D'an and the Modal Nodes,
cantina band,
otherwise known as the top song
on the Sexy Times playlist.
Which may sound weird to you,
but in Star Wars canon--
this is a hundred percent true--
this genre of music
is called Jizz-wail.
-(laughter)
-Uh, absolutely true.
Uh... J-I-Z-Z W-A-I-L.
-It's called Jizz-wail.
-HANNAH: They saw it coming.
-Yeah.
-Aah...!
Aah...!
Hundred points to Hannah Hart!
They didn't hear that-- Hannah
said, "I saw that coming."
(laughter)
-What...?
-Very good.
-(applause, whistling)
Jizz-wailing is also a term
for crying
while you masturbate
to Bea Arthur
on the Star Wars
Holiday Special.
(laughter)
So, comedians,
what is a Star Wars sex move
that you would do
to the cantina band song?
-Mamrie. -One in the Pink,
Two in the Binks.
-Yes, points! Very good!
-(laughter)
(laughing):
Very good.
Oh, meesa... oh...
-(laughter)
-Uh, Grace.
Jabba in the Butt.
-Yes, points. Very good.
-(laughter)
-Hannah.
-It's a crap!
-Yeah, points! Very good!
-(laughter)